well guys thank you very much here I am
joined by the rolls-royce CEO toastin
Muller Aquos thank you very much for
showing us this beautiful car
tell me about sales these don't come
inexpensive no they don't then that's
for good reasons because we are at the
pinnacle of automotive luxury Rose Royce
one of the or not the most well known
luxury brand on earth and these cars
cost quite some amount of money but for
good reasons because what you get is
excellent substance and I'll show you
that in a minute
well we can go inside two seconds but
tell me about sales but you had a record
year last year do you expect another
record here yeah we had for the four
last four years one record year after
the next and I'm very confident that we
should see again this year record year
we probably break and crack for the
first time four thousand it's a an
annual sales for this year four thousand
billionaires out there just waiting to
get was roasting SEC I'm gonna pretend
to be one of those billionaires well
they all look the same from the outside
roughly but no damn it
that's up to you however you would like
to Commission the car so they okay I'm
gonna join me on the other side here I'm
gonna attempt to step in here and I hope
I don't blunder this is obviously my
first step into a Rolls Royce I should
act like I know what I'm doing but
clearly I don't and we are back here all
right so uh tell tell me about some of
the luxury features on on inside I mean
this car here celebrates what we called
bespoke which gives you as customer the
chance to individualize the cars up to
your own fingerprint and that currently
is called a Metropolitan car which shows
beautiful marquetry not only on the
picnic tables but all over the place
marquetry which is very much related to
cities city landscapes every marquetry
here takes at least a couple of days to
finish it's comprised out of 500 little
different wood parts and then of course
edit a lovely embroidery all over the
car are you really are you really
supposed to eat in the back of a Rolls
Royce on your picnic table are not only
eating but you can also have of course
drinks in here we have picnic campus in
the cars we have fridges in the cars so
everything you like I saw I suppose
you're if you're a billionaire your mom
isn't
impose the no eating in the backseat
rule definitely not and it is comes also
with style to do that here in
rolls-royce here will you do this is
full style full of fashion almost tell
us about how billionaires differ across
the globe what are some of the unique
requests I would say that don't differ a
lot by all means because they are very
cosmopolitan people probably the most
cosmopolitan I've ever met many of our
clients do have residences in all
international cities worldwide they are
on private jets all over the place
and for that reason they are very
demanding they never accept any no and
for good reasons because when you pay
that amount of money for one of our cars
you can accept the best and expect the
best what percent of your customers buy
more than one Rolls Royce quite some so
we have customers we have the whole
collection of cars so all different
models we are talking here about
customers who do have even up to over
hundred cars in the garage in average at
least 1012 cars in the garage so people
who are I would say have garages like we
do have wardrobes
yeah well obvious question is who washes
them all probably not the owners I'm not
the owners definitely not we've
obviously seen some geopolitical risk
things in Russia the market is down how
have your sales been going in Russia I
mean we are satisfied how Russia
developed particularly in the first half
year this year and that might be also
due to the case that people invested
their rubles into some what I would call
real assets and froze Royce is a proper
investment keeps the value of a long
long time so we have seen that our sales
were soaring in Russia particular in the
first half year apart what percent were
they up I mean they were up around 15 20
percent compared to the previous years
which is quite substantial on the
overall market circumstances yeah okay
well next time I have an extra 350,000
pounds to spend I'm worried about
declining ruble I'm a park it inside a
Rolls Royce and I'll be careful not to
spill I just know where I'd spill all
the Cheerios or where my kids would
spill for Cheerios in the back with that
we will send it back to London from
inside let's could safely be called a
comfortable interior